so we've spent a lot of time talking
about the formal principles of machine
learning in this module i'm going to
talk more about the empirical aspects of
machine practice
so recall the three design decisions for
a machine learning
algorithm
first set up the hypothesis class
training objective and
optimization average
and each of these design decisions has
itself a bunch of different
so for the hypothesis class
uh you have to specify the feature
extractor fee
new features quadratic features and you
also have to specify the architecture
the linear predictor or to use a one
layer neural network or a two layer
neural network and how many hidden units
do you have when you have a neural
network
so for the training objective um there's
a question of what should the loss
function be
the hinge loss or there's just a class
um and then what about regularization
you use regularization uh what is should
its strength be
the optimization algorithm
even the vanilla stochastic gradient
descent has
two hyper parameters one is the number
of epochs
another one is the step size
here it's a constant but maybe you want
it to be decreasing or you want to use a
fancier adaptive sepsis rule at a grad
or atom
if you're training deep neural networks
there's more things to think about
there's initialization how much noise do
you add in
retraining
use a batch size for caster gradient
descent as batch size 1 do you use 4 16
um what about using a drop out rate to a
guard against overfitting
so quickly you see that the design space
becomes quite big and it's really kind
of like choose your own
venture
some of these design decisions can be
made uh based on principles for example
if you believe that your data has some
sort of periodic structure you can add
periodic features
but many of these if not most of the
design decisions are
really unclear
and you sometimes just want an automatic
way for these science decisions made
so each of these design decisions is
called a hyper parameter hyper
parameters are the design decisions that
may need to be made before running the
learning so how do you choose these
so how about you we choose the design of
the hyper parameters to minimize the
training error
so this is a
really bad idea because
the optimum would be to just include all
the features use no regularization train
forever and really drive the training
loss down down down
but remember the training loss is not
the quantity that we remember about
okay so how about we choose hyper
parameters to minimize the test error
so
this might generate actually good hyper
parameters
but this is also bad because now you're
looking at the test
set which makes it an unreliable
estimate of the actual error
so what do we do then
so the solution is to use a held out
validation set it's also known as a
holdout set or development set
and this set is just taken out of the
training set and it's used to optimize
hyper parameters
urinals
so here's a picture you leave the test
set alone it's isolated from what you're
doing here
and you take the training set and you
divide it into a validation set which is
usually a small fraction
but large enough to get reliable
estimates and then the rest of the
training set
so now for each setting the hyper
parameters you can train on this train
minus the validation and then evaluate
the validation and then you can choose
the hyper parameters
to be the ones that
minimize the error on this validation
so now i'm going to talk about
model development strategy
so we've talked a lot about uh the
formal machinery
and i'm just going to walk you through
kind of a typical
development cycle
so what you do is you start out by
splitting the data you get some data and
you split it into train validation and
test you lock away the test set
and you look at the data not the test
data the train or validation data to get
intuition you want to understand
uh what kind of properties your problem
that you're trying to solve has
and then you repeat
the following
so you implement a model architecture or
a feature extractor
or you adjust some hyper parameters and
then you run the learning algorithm you
train a model
and then you look at sandy check the
train and validation errors along the
way make sure the training error is
going down making sure the validation
error more or less goes down it goes up
that means you're over fitting
you also want to look at
at least for linear classifiers the
weights if they're interpretable get uh
against any check and get some intuition
and you also want to look at some
prediction errors you want to understand
if the model is not doing as well as you
like
how is it making how is it screwing up
and you repeat this until you're
satisfied and then finally you unlock
the test set you evaluate on the test
set to get your final error rates that
you put in your
so let's walk through an example of how
works okay so i'm going to take this
simple example of um a named ntt
recognition
um so here the input is a string
which contains a name along with a word
to the left and the word to the right to
offer some context
and the output is going to be whether
x
excluding this initial and final word is
a person or not in this case gavin
newsom is uh plus one
person
okay so now i'm going to uh code this up
so
we have um ner.py
so this is a file um
that we're going to use and uh this file
actually depends on
submission.py.util.py
from your sentiment homework so if you
have that you can plug it in with code
and see it in action for yourself
um so let me just walk through this
first let's read the training examples
the validation examples and then we're
going to learn a predictor
this returns a set of weights
um we're going to output the weights to
a file
output the
error analysis to file which i'll show
you in a second and then this part is
commented out because we don't want to
run
uh evaluation on a test set just yet
okay so the first thing we want to do is
just open up this training file just to
get some intuition for what the data
looks like okay so each line here is a
training example um this is why this is
a minus which means not a person and
this is x
mauritius into mauritius is uh not a
person
um us is not a person malaysia's not a
person
sarah pakowski is a person
plus one moscow is not a person
um and so on
see all these training examples we have
around 7000
okay so so now let's begin by
implementing um
feature extractor i have to implement
this
function it's going to take x
and
just to uh
put a comment what does x looks like so
example x
is the string here
um and then i'm going to define the
feature vector um to be a dictionary
of upload so this is going to be a
sparse representation of the future
vector
um okay so that is the simplest feature
extractor it happens to be the empty
vector with no features but let's just
see
what happens
um start simple so starting really
simple here
okay so let's do python
py
uh we see that across a number of
iterations
test error is uh really high 72 per
percent error
this is not surprising because we
haven't we don't have any features
okay so let's add some features so
uh maybe a kind of obvious feature to
add is uh looking at the identity of
entity
so what we're gonna do is i'm gonna
process x a little bit so i'm going to
split it
into a bunch of tokens
so a list containing took
mauritius and into
and then i'm going to split it up into
the left
entity and the right
and this is going to be token 0 tokens 1
through um
everything except for the last
token and then i'm going to have the
last
okay so i'm just going to divide x into
these three parts
so now i can define a feature template
so let's define the feature template to
be fee
entity
is um and then i'm entertaining is now
an array so i'm going to join it and i'm
going to set that to 1. so this is a
binary uh this is one line that
represents
one feature template but it instantiates
into
a whole bunch of different
features one for every possible entity
okay so i'm naming the feature in a way
that makes it
really interpretable
so we'll see how this is quite useful
okay so let's um run this
see what happens
and now the error is uh 19
it's in progress the training error is
really low which means that we're really
fitting the training error
um so now let's go and inspect what
happens we look at the weights here
um so this is sorted from positive to
negative
here we have the feature name and
and the weight
so up here you can see that entity is
and these generally happen to be
um and if you look at the bottom
we see things which are not names
okay so this is a good sanity check that
says suggest that the learning is
working
um let's look at the error analysis so
this shows you on the validation set
on the predictions that the model makes
so here is the first
input
um
on the true
label is one
person but we predicted minus one
which is wrong
and here i'm showing the the features
that and their particular weights so
entity is a romero that has a feature
value of one its weight is zero the
weight of zero generally means that it
never saw this feature at training time
so therefore the score is zero so we
have no idea what to do example
um here is another example of the senate
it says entity is senate senate and uh
senate has a weight of negative one so
we have a score of negative one and we
make prediction
um so let me just look through these
incorrect predictions
margaret allah
flamed
was midfielder
and you can kind of see well
it's unreasonable to expect that the
entities have been seen
before
so why don't we try to use the context
to figure out whether uh the name is the
entity
the name is a person or not
so let's go over here um
i'm going to
define a feature template left is
left
and
right is right
um
so this is a feature template left is
blank as we've written past and i'm
instantiating this feature for this
particular x
which is taking um the actual value left
here okay so i added two feature
templates um let's run this
and now we can see that
the error rate has
gone down to 11
right
um
notice that the training error doesn't
actually go down as fast because with
more features sometimes it's harder to
optimize but that's okay because we
don't care about the training and we
only care about
the test error going down um one one uh
note is that this says test error but
i'm actually
um
passing in here the validation set a
learn predictor the function turns out
test error because it doesn't
have any idea where
okay so let's look at the weights
so
at the top
still uh features that's look at the
entity
clinton um
nelson
here is some examples left is minister
so if you have minister someone that is
probably a person president someone as a
person
um if you look down here you see that if
the left context is the
the weight is minus which means that the
something is not a person so this all
makes sense it's good sanity check
let's look at the error analysis so now
we're getting a royal romero correct um
let's see what we're getting wrong so
it is blamed
um
felix and attila
um never uh i guess we've seen that
person before um
workers party
um it's never seen this
um
and you know now you can think more
brainstorm and think well
could we maybe we don't aren't gonna see
the exact
stream match of an entity but you can
maybe break it down
pieces
so what i'm going to do is for each word
in entity
i'm going to say entity contains
a word
so it's pretty easy to write feature
templates um
and this is very intuitive so this
feature template just says does this
entity contain a
particular word
in the entity
okay so let's run this and now the error
rate is going down to six percent okay
so we're making good progress um
let's look at the weights i need to
check this
um so an entity contains
um this feature will fire both for
clinton and also as well as bill clinton
um
and these contains features are
generally seen more general and they're
given high weight
at the bottom
again if it has new in it it's probably
like new york or something and that's
not probably not going to be a person
contains newsroom i don't know too many
folks
um
error analysis uh let's see what's wrong
here we're still getting this wrong
sometimes you just
going on we're still getting this
kurdistan party
one wrong
um
iron man and sometimes it's it's kind of
hard to know what to do so
um
you know let's just try something else
let's say
uh going in the spirit of decomposing
the entity into words we can go further
and have patterns that match on prefix
prefixes and suffixes
so we can say the entity contains the
prefix
word and just
arbitrarily choose the first four
uh characters
um it changes the suffix
word and i'm gonna choose last
characters
so first for characters
um last character
okay
all right so let's
see how this does
now we can see that the error rate is
going down to four percent so we made a
little bit of progress uh there
um i'm actually going to call it uh
quits for now just in the interest of
time we've made a lot of progress from
seventy percent error to only four
percent error
but remember this is only on the
validation set
so now comes the final
trial
see how well
this does on the test set so read in the
test set and then evaluate
the predictor on this
test set
and i'm going to print it out so let's
run this
and hope that we didn't overfit
um and here we actually
did even better on the test set than
validation set which sometimes happens
um
there's just always some randomness here
and so we ended up with four percent uh
iterate which is um pretty good for
uh 10 minutes before
so in practice it's things are probably
not going to go as smooth as this this
is just kind of illustrative example um
to illustrate the the kind of process
here
okay so there's much more to be said
about the practice of machine learning
um but
so
i'm just going to give you kind of some
general
you know advice
many of these tips are kind of related
to having best software engineering
practice
so the first thing i want to talk about
is starting simple so the wrong thing to
do is code up a really complicated
learning algorithm run it on a million
examples and watch again fashion burn
wonder what happened
um
simplify um both in terms of running on
small subsets of your data
maybe even synthetic data and also start
with a simple baseline model we started
with a literally a classifier that have
zero features and maybe one feature just
so we can see and understand what it's
doing so this is important because it
allows you to work in a regime where
things are understandable
and also importantly
things run quickly
so you want fast iteration time like
what we you just saw was you we can
quickly try something get a result try
something weird result if you have to
wait
10 hours to get a result then you're
just not going to make as much progress
because you won't be rigged
um
one
sanity check that i would recommend is
uh try to train on very few examples
like five examples and see if you can
overfit see if you can drive the
training error to zero
now of course doing so is not going to
give you a useful model
but it will
tell you whether your the machinery is
working or not if you're unable to fit
five examples that
something is wrong it could mean that
your data is too noisy or you lack
certain features or your model is not
expressive enough
or your learning algorithm isn't working
maybe you try to optimize a zero loss or
something i don't know but
anyway it's a good sanity check
uh the second thing is log everything
print out metrics
uh um so track the training lots and the
validation lots over time make sure that
it's going down as intended record the
hyper parameters
that you're using to train so you can
keep track of what you actually did to
get through your result for now
statistics of the data set how many
features how many examples um the model
uh how many weights are there the norm
of the weights predictions as you saw
and it was really useful to have this
file that showed you
exactly how the model makes each
prediction it just gives you a lot more
insight
finally
uh spend some time figuring how to
organize your experiments i like to have
each run i make go into a separate
folder which you can save
um
and so then later back later you can go
back and check
all the models the predictions and
a record of all the hyper parameters
that you use so that you just have an
idea of what you did
and then a note about reporting your
results
it's important to run your experiments
multiple times
particularly with different random seeds
so you make sure that your
results are stable and reliable and then
you can report the mean and the standard
deviation over
these random seeds
and finally um
we often in machine learning tend to be
guilty of distilling everything down
into one number as a test error
um but in in practice we might be
interested in multiple metrics in
particular it's important to make sure
that
if you get five percent error understand
what those errors are sometimes it's
useful to report the error rates on
different
minority groups or subpopulations if you
have access to that information
and generally be cognizant of the biases
in your model
okay to summary summarize we've talked
about the practice of machine learning
first make sure you have good data
hygiene
separate your test set leave it alone
and divide your training set into a
validation and the rest don't look at
the touch set
but do look at the training or
validation set to understand the shape
of your data so that you can
have intuition for
deciding how to model the
start simple
and finally
there's a lot
of design decisions which can be
overwhelming
at first and
the most important thing is to practice
doing that
doing experimentation so that you can
start developing an intuition of what
hyperparameters
matter and what kind of effect they have
and then eventually developing a set of
best practices for yourself
okay that's all